hello everyone i am yangon shi from
technion
today i will talk about our research
work on online painting with the
venetian
rights this is a joint work with
professor yuar and mak
and professor shaikh kutin
in an online paging problem we are given
a main memory of session and the cache
of set key
the requests over the pages in the main
memory comes in an online function in t
runs at each one t
if the requested page segment t is not
in the cash configuration
then we see that a cache means happens
in such a case the algorithm needs to
invite some page
in the cash configuration and bring the
requested page in
the cost of online online paging
algorithm
is defined to be the number of the cash
misses
and the objective is to minimize the
number of the cache misses
given the fourth sequence of the pattern
required
we can define the next rail time not
a page i with respect to a run t to be
the first run of t when the page i is
requested
in related work in 1966
it is proved that the optimum can be
achieved
by an offline algorithm which always
invites
a page with the largest nuts
we refer to such an algorithm as
furthest in the future
fit if
the regret of an online pitching
algorithm
is defined to be the difference between
the cause
incurred by this algorithm and the
minimum
our goal is to design a rampaging
algorithm with the vanishing required
which means that the ratio of the
regulation to the number of the runs
capital t
tends to be zero when t when t tends to
be infinity
however a online printing algorithm with
one zero bytes is impossible under the
conventional setting
consider the scenario where the n
equal to k plus 1 and the request
sequence
is generated uniformly and independently
at random
it can be proved that in such a case
the expected the expectation of the
optimum
is abounded by big o t over k
low key well the expected cost
of any random algorithm act is lower
bounded by
omega t over k
therefore in our work we will consider a
setting where the olympic algorithm
can receive predictions which
can be possibly generated by machine
learning algorithms
in particular in a nut predictor
the predictions are generated as a
sequence
as for the as of as the predictions of
the real nuts
and these predictions are generated in
an online fashion
and for not predictor we define the
cumulative prediction error
to be the number of the runs when the
predictions
do not match the real nuts
different from the related works focus
on the single predictor case
in our work we consider the multiple
predictor case
these multiple predictors can be
implemented with the machine learning
for cutting algorithms
that are trained over different data
sets or
using different machine learning models
like the model that are robust to
adversarial attacks
when we make an assumption that when we
are provided with accesses to multiple
predictors
then at least one of them has a low
cumulative prediction error
that is sublinear in t we refer to such
an
assumption as a good predictor
assumption
since the predictions or not predictor
is generated in
analyte fashion there are two models to
define
how we can access the predictions
the first one is called default
information access model
under such a model of the prediction
of every predictor is revealed to the
main algorithm
at every run the second one is called
the bandit access model
in such a model the of the main
algorithm needs to make a choice over
the predictors
and then it can only access the
prediction of the chosen predictor at
the current runs
so obviously the second model
is more interesting but also more
challenging
from the perspective of techniques
that now our main results are summarized
as follows
we will start with the single predictor
case
and for the single predict case we
develop an
algorithm theme which simulates the
operations of phi types but replacing
the real nuts
with values that are derived from the
predictions
and we prove that such an algorithm has
a request a
big o or attack which is the
cumulative prediction error plus k which
is the cash size
by the good predicted predictor
assumption
such a regret is the vanishing regrets
for the multiple predictor setting with
the
full information access model or we can
run our
algorithm theme with uh
with respect to each given predictor and
in parallel and then makes them with the
random algorithm
proposed by blam and birch in 2000
in this way we can get a vanishing
required for the multiple predictor
setting
um like this
and the foreign information access model
however
the algorithm proposed by blam and birch
in 2000
requires to know the cash configuration
or algorithm that always follows
a fixed predictor which is unavailable
in the
banded excess model so to overcome this
obstacle
we will utilize some combinatorial
properties
of our algorithm sim proposed for the
single predictor case to show that
such an algorithm can always be chased
without knowing its current
configuration
cache configuration and in this way we
obtain
a vanishing regret for the for this
bandit access model and it is expressed
as this formula
now i want to talk about something about
the measurements of
the prediction errors in the related
works
the cumulative prediction errors is
often measured with the sharp
the r1 knob which is defined to be the
l1 norm
of the prediction sequence minus the
sequence of the real nuts
recall that in our work the cumulative
prediction error
is defined to be the number of the runs
when the prediction
doesn't match the real nuts
and we also call this measurement as the
number of
error runs and it is easy to see that
the number of the elements it is never
larger than the
l1 norm meanwhile the l1 norm
it can be omega t times larger than
sharp error runs so we can see that
the measurements that we have already
described
is better than the measurement used in
the
in these related works
in some religious works in their
analysis not their main results
they also consider another measurements
the number of the inverted pairs
for pair around t and t prime we see
that they are an
inverted pair if their real nuts
and their predictions from across
like this like this formula
and we define the number of the rotate
runs to be the number of the runs t
such that there exists another run d
prime so that c
and g prime form an inverted pair
and it we can prove that
the number of the inverted runs is
at most two times larger than the number
of the inverted
pairs however the number of the
inverted pairs it can be only t times
larger
than the number of the inverted runs so
we can say that the number of the
university round is actually better than
the number of the
inverted pairs at the environments and
the number of linear rounds and the
error runs
these two measurements are incomparable
because we can contract
instances so that the former one is
omega t
times larger than the lighter one and
right
was a you know another instance
um and now we define a refined
measurement
of the prediction errors it will count
the runs that are counted by
both uh the errorland
and sharp error runs and the inverted
runs
so as you can see it's such a
measurement it will be stronger than all
these
measurements discussed above and also
our main results
were described with these
measurements everyone's they also hold
for such a strong
measurement now let's talk about the
related work
first in the uh people by
le correas like curious um i thought on
ic
about 18 and in the paper by
lohati he asked 2000
they consider the online paging problem
with the single predictor
and their results are expressed as
competitive ratios
their competitive ratios cannot be
converted to a
result in the form of a vanishing regret
this is because the algorithms are based
on the marking of wisdom
and we prove that any marking algorithm
cannot give managing required even when
they are provided with the
fully correct prediction sequence
in the paper by we um
[Music]
approach random 2020
in the if he also considered the
underpainting problem
with the single predictor our agree our
results for the single predictor case
can be
viewed as a refinement over there with
his results
because we are using a stronger
measurement
of the prediction errors
in the paper by antonio the states at
all
on sml 20 we consider the single
predictor sighting
for the unknown problem of the metric
attack system
which is a more general system than
pigeon
however the measurements that you use
for the cumulative prediction errors
is incomparable with the iowan norm
and it is also incomparable with our
measurements
in the paper by
putting sml 19 we consider
the a unless rental problem
and the multiple predictor settings
notice that uh in the online
scale window problem the length of the
request
is implicitly bonded by the
cost of purchase or buying the sky
equipments however in our case the
challenge mainly comes from the
unbounded
request sequence this is a major
difference between
our work and their work
so now let me describe our algorithms
and our analysis
we start with a single predictor case
and the
proposed algorithm sim which simulates
the
optimal algorithm fit type but replacing
the actual nuts with the remd
predictions
defined as the followers
so if we do not look at this kind of
line
then the remnant predictions it works as
follows it will initialize
the initialize the the lambda prediction
of
every page to be capital z plus one
for some large enough capital z and
then it will update the
lambda prediction to the given
predictions
of a page whenever this page is
requested
so this is a very easy explanation
a clear implementation but we need to
know what this
colored line want to see i want to
explain what this color i want to see
and let's first see this blue part of
this colored line
and each this line is necessary
for us to get rid of the l1 now
measurements
and accommodate the element
measurements this
this blue part it can be interpreted as
uh correcting the predictions the
light has already been found to be wrong
and
i mean the pages that are predicted to
arrive earlier
or not but haven't arrived
so let's see an example suppose that
the n equal to three and k equals to two
the initial cash configuration contains
page one and 2.
in reality the page 1 is only requested
at the beginning
and the end but in prediction the page 1
is also requested as
run 3 and without
the blue patch now we can see that i
asked page
after round three then the page one
always has
the smallest next round time and it is
narrow invited from the cache
configuration in that case it will cause
a loss of omega t
meanwhile the error runs with it will
give a cumulative error or a constant
so to accommodate the
these measurements we do need these blue
parts
now let's see these orange parts this is
an
additional condition to help us to work
with the measurement in what it runs
and so they'll consider an example where
we have to
have n equal to 3 and k equal to 2
and in the in the request
sequence in reality the predicament is
never requested
however in the prediction it is
requested at the beginning
and in such a case without the
orange parts then i'd run through our
algorithm we'll update the prediction of
the page 2
to capital z and may invert it because
it has a very large
remedy prediction and then at
launch 3 it may update the
predominantly prediction of page rate to
capital d
and may eract it and so on and so forth
and in such case our algorithm may have
a loss
of capital t
however the measurements uh
sharp inverted runs it will give a
cumulative
error of a constant so in such case we
need the
first part of this original uh
first inequality of these orange parts
to help us to deal with this
measurements
and the second measurement is to ensure
that
the inverted pairs are that we can't
are not caused by our operation of
increasing the remedy prediction or some
page
to a large enough v
yes this is the basic idea of
setting the rmd predictions
now let's see some definitions and
notions that we
will use in our analysis for the
cache configurations of the algorithm
fit f and same
we define the intersection to be the set
of the pages
at one t that are both in uh the
calculations of them
and the distance is different to be
clean minus the size of the intersection
we define the troublemakers to be a set
of special ones
that satisfy this condition
this condition can be interpreted as
follows
at a tremendous run t our algorithms
seem it will invade
a page from the intersection
but the optimal algorithm fit f we will
not
invict this page instead it will keep
this
the page in its cache until it is
requested
for the first time after t and we call
this
time as t run t prime so as we can see
we our loss will be increased by one at
run t prime because a cache miss will
happen through the
in our algorithm but not to the
algorithm feed f
that's why we call it runty as the
troublemaker
and so now we have such a theory
the loss of our algorithm sim is bounded
by
big o the number of the prediction
errors
plus k the cache size plus
the number of the troublemakers minus
the number of the runs where the loss
decreases
the basic idea of pro probing ethereum
is as follows first a run that
increases the distance will neither dig
increase nor decrease our loss this is
because in such
runs both the optimal algorithm fit f
and our algorithms theme
need to invade some page and we in fact
they need to invest
different page in the intersection so
the loss doesn't change and it doesn't
change in such a run
second the number of the rounds where
the distance decreases
it can be um expanded by the number of
the rounds
will decrease related distance increases
plus the cash size this statement is
obvious
and three a run that increases the
distance
can always blame a run that is uh
counted by the cumulative prediction
error
because otherwise the the algorithm fit
f and the algorithm theme
shouldn't even different page in the
intersection
and the fourth round that is counted by
the cumulative prediction error
can be blamed by at most twice because
each time it is blamed it will the run
that is the page that is requested at
that run
will be evicted from either the cash of
the feed f
or the cash or theme
so putting all these statements together
we know that we can redeem we can reduce
the problem of analyzing the cost
to counting the runs where the
distance doesn't change but our cause
our loss increases
and it can be further proved like
such kinds of runs are caused by either
a run
that increases the distance of a travel
microphone
so now it remains to count the
troublemaker run
and in our people we propose a labeling
mechanism
to analyze to kind the troublemakers
and our main idea is to show that
every travel maker can be mapped to
either
a grant well that is counted by the
cumulative prediction error
all around that's the loss decreases
and we will use the labels to ensure
that
not too many pages are mapped to the
same
round that is counted by the uh
cumulative prediction error or the run
with the
the cause with the loss of reason
and in fact the first we will show that
the first mapping
will be a two-to-one mapping and the
lighter one will be a one to one might
be
and uh in for a troublemaker run gamma
when the one remember our algorithm sim
invites a page
like this beer page and then we will
find a page
in the cache configuration of our
algorithm
but not in the cache configuration of
the fit f
and such algorithm such a page should be
on
we should be unlabeled like this correct
page
and we will label it uh
until in the unique page the bill page
is requested
and now we will consider three cases the
first
case is that the label page
the card page is requested earlier than
the invictus page the fair page
and our obvious theme keeps the cad page
in his cache configuration until it
is requested then as you can see
at this catalog the there will be a
cache miss
happened to the feed f algorithm but not
to our algorithm
so at this category uh the
loss our loss will decrease by one so in
such case
we can map this uh travel maker to a
lost degrees in run
the second case that we consider is the
bill wrong bill page is requested
earlier
than the cash page and in such a case
we can see that the run gamma can be
mapped to a prediction error
because without the prediction error the
the algorithm theme needs should invade
the page
catch cad page instead of the beer page
because the kite page arrives later than
the bare page
the third scenario is more complicated
here with your assume that the kind page
it arrives earlier than the bare page
the current page
is the page labeled at the beginning
and however our algorithm may erase this
page
before it is requested for the first
time
and in such case we will find another
only word page
in our cache but not in the intersection
like this rabbit page then we will label
this
rabbit page this is like a regular
regular case of the two cases that we
discussed about
and we will keeps finding the new
unlabeled pages in our cache and
not but not in the cache of the uh fit f
and we will label it so on and so forth
the question is how to ensure that we
can always
find uh early blood page to label
in our cache but not in the intersection
one important observation here for this
question
is that the the bare page
it will exist in the cache of the fit f
but not in the intersection during this
whole period
so by the matrix we can always find a
page
may be different pages in different
rounds but can always find a page
throughout this period that is in our
cash
but not in the cash of the free time
so yes this is a basic idea to find the
only blood page in this way we solved
our problems
for the single predictor case
and now let's check the multiple
predictor site here
for the full information access model as
mentioned earlier
we will simulate our algorithms theme
with respect to each given predictor
and we will multiplex mix these
algorithms
with a random algorithm proposed by
bloom and birch
in 2000 in their algorithm
they will run off a long stateless
online learning algorithm over the
predictors
and each time the unlearning algorithm
chooses a new predictor
the algorithm will make a switch between
the
catch configurations to catch the
new algorithm with respect to the new
predictor
and the algorithm can help us to get
advantage required
for the full information access model
however
the algorithm needs to know the cache
configuration of every algorithm follows
each predictor
this information is unavailable and the
bandit access
model so to overcome this obstacle
we will use a chasing procedure
instead of switching the cache
configuration
in particular we will start we will
reach that same
every time the online learning algorithm
chooses a new predictor
we will reach that algorithm seen in an
onset manner
from the current cash configuration with
respect to the new
or predictor and this technique works
very well
because our analysis are same for the
single predictor case
it holds regardless of our initial cash
configuration
and particularly even if our cash
configuration is different
from the initial cash configuration of
the a fit f algorithm
our all our previous analysis still
holds
this has probably helped us to ensure
that the chasing process
works well and another question here is
that
how could we build the feedback to the
stateless and
learning algorithm because in the bandit
access mode under the planet excess
model
we cannot know the cost incurred by the
algorithm that always follows the same
prediction so this problem is not
trivial
and can can we directly use our cost
the or cost cost per hour algorithm as a
proclamation or estimation of the cost
that's of the algorithm that always
follows the fixed
predictor the answer is no because the
cost cost by our algorithm is a stateful
cost and we cannot directly feed it
to a stillness and learning of reason we
solve this algorithm by omitting the
first key different requests
after the algorithm theme is restarted
and we only
feed the costs included by the remaining
page page requests to the stateless
online learning algorithm and we prove
that
the cost that we feed to the learning
algorithm is actually stateless
this solves our technical problems and
help
us to get a renting required for the
multiple predictor society
that's all thank you